explain a little bit about without
getting into any one of the uh current
situations explain a little bit as to
how you think about uh the national
strategic defense implications of
bitcoin itself from like a u.s
perspective
well this is where it comes down to this
conversation that we talked about
earlier
form
software is tricky
everything about software
is hard it's invisible it's inherently
unintuitive
it's complex and confusing the size and
complexity of software scales to the
point where it can have infinite states
it can be it's like proteus it can take
any shape and it can run through like
every time a software runs a new
subroutine it's technically a wholly
different thing and you can have
thousands of subroutines in a single
piece of software
two people can have two different
abstractions and both be correct when
they describe the form and function of
software remember because these are just
abstractions
like software is only a set of
instructions that tells the discrete
state machine what to do so if you call
it gold but i call it a gun neither of
us are technically incorrect
more importantly
software can perform two functions at
once
okay so i get accused all the time of
being a hammer that looks like that
looks at bitcoin like it's a nail
and but but
the implication being well obviously
it's a monetary system so so the
screwdrivers are calling it a screw the
hammer is calling it a nail and people
don't understand that it can be both
things at once at the same time it's
software
it is both things at once well so
and so so
you remember your question was about
explaining the national strategic
implications of of bitcoin if you want
to understand it
don't look at the software
look at the hardware piece look at the
thing that everyone can see
okay this is how you describe the
national strategic implications of
bitcoin this is how you explain why
there is no replacement for bitcoin
people
both animals and people have been trying
to search for a substitute for this
humans have been doing it for 200 000
years
okay a way to defend their property more
effectively and by the way
the more energy you use the better your
defense is that's why you don't want to
take a knife to a gunfight
energy is good the power that you
project the more powerful a hunk of
metal is that defends your property
that protects it against denial of
service attacks is good and by the way
this allows you to actually physically
stop an attacker a denial surface
attacker it's not just a deterrent it's
like proof of stake this is
ability to physically stop the attacker
so when you think of that go or go guide
continue
so
my goal from the very beginning when
talking to policymakers
this is what's super frustrating
like i said i'm an astronautical
engineer in the space force and a u.s
national defense fellow at mit my job
what you pay me for
is to understand what this form will be
in the future and to posture this
country
to make sure that we have the most
powerful thing that we're not taking a
knife to a gunfight in the future
and so it's super frustrating when
people are talking to me about bitcoin
as if it's strictly a financial system
or strictly a monetary network
and acting like me that i'm not
qualified to be talking about this kind
of stuff
and it's also super frustrating to watch
a bunch of bankers
a bunch of business people a bunch of
finance people try to explain it because
then they get confused and they say oh
it's the digital version of this
and it's like you could have a phd in
economics and not understand the
socio-technical implications of this in
fact most of them don't
right
and then or they'll go well okay it's
digital energy you see we we take a
state machine and we digitally partition
it across a distributed ledger and the
people who are allowed to write on it
are the ones that find the knots and and
it's like miners searching for gold and
then we act surprised when a bunch of
people get freaking confused
about what you're doing or if you treat
it strictly as a property they're going
to say why
what what makes bitcoin different what
makes bitcoin different than any other
type of digital property or digital
asset out there so
so
my goal is to just
take this complex technology and boil it
down to something that anyone with no
background can understand can and then
make informed policy decisions on it
because if you treat it like a digital
version of this
your policy is going to look very
different
than the digital version of this because
if you think it's just digital property
then you might say okay well maybe it's
a threat to usd hegemony or this or that
but if you realize that this is the
future of warfare what happens when we
just when we scale this up
and it's not just me but now it's an
entire army of people what do we call
that war
it's called war
okay
nations
live and die and are created and are
uncreated by their ability to understand
what form this will take and to be good
at that game in the future this is how
we defend everything that we value
people forget this and if a new
technology emerges if a new one of these
emerges
banning it is not an option
you can't ban your adversary from using
this right so when orbin the engineer
creates cannons he was the guy that
invented this
he figured out how to iron cast cylinder
fill one end with gunpowder fill another
end with a bullet he takes that
technology to constantinople and he
offers it offers to build it to
constantine constantine turns him down
says he can't afford it
you see the logical flaw there correct
because orvin goes to a 19 year old kid
the sultan sultan mahmud
and within a year
they're shooting down the walls of
constantinople the only you don't get
the option
right you have to buy it you if you
can't afford the cannon you buy orbin
you buy
von braun
okay so so these are
this technology has multiple shelling
points in history we use it for warfare
we devise mechanisms so that people pay
fees to other people to wield this
technology on their behalf correct
and that's precisely what we're doing
with this technology people who buy
bitcoin are subsidizing the development
of a new weapon system a new defense
industrial complex
and which one do you think is more
ethical well definitely the bitcoin
mining the digital protection of
property rights is not only uh more
ethical but it's also uh i would argue
much more uh effective in achieving
world peace because at the end of the
day
you end up actually knowing with almost
a
high degree of certainty or actually
with a high degree of certainty it is
impossible to penetrate
versus as we are watching right now in
certain areas of the world um some
people are confused as to you can use
the uh uh the gun uh and those types of
weapons uh and there's a question can we
actually overpower another region
another army another uh
kind of citizenry and when you look into
the digital world you know that it can't
be penetrated
in every way that you look at this
technology
what is the current conversation doesn't
make sense what is being discussed at
the national strategic level is
incongruent to what this technology is
and what it represents
obviously
the thing that projects more power the
defense technology that uses more energy
is a better defense system
obviously
the technology that can preserve
citizens private property rights without
spilling blood without the
unfortunate side effects of this is more
ethical
and obviously trying to ban this from
your country is only going to give your
adversary an advantage over you read
history read what happened when
whitehead goes invented the torpedo and
the royal navy the powerful navy turned
him down and said i'm not going to
invest in this technology because it
represents a threat to my naval hegemony
you don't get the option
not to par to turn
where this technology takes you hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time